what really is one of their core values
is that trust is built through building
relationships now that doesn't happen in
a three-day business trip you know an
israeli flying to the ua thinking he'll
come back with you know an initial
understanding of a business transaction
it's not going to happen
welcome to 20-minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by jvengers a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance opposed labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright xl
serena partners and in media partnership
with c-tech
welcome to 20-minute leaders meet arona
maskiel a cross-cultural business
consultant trainer mentor and coach with
extensive experience in working with
global companies
american by birth israeli by choice and
finnish at heart arona is a fan of
building bridges and not enthusiastic
about walls with her team at training cq
she helps close the gap between cultures
so people can work together more
efficiently
[Music]
welcome to 20 minute leaders thank you
so much for joining me how are you today
good i'm fine thank you for having me
this is exciting i'm excited to talk to
you about globalization about cultures
about communication and about the way
that
that we are dealing with this globalized
world which you know on one hand it's
incredible on the other hand it presents
new challenges that perhaps we weren't
really trained for and we don't really
understand yet
different groups of people grew up in
different mentalities and different
traditions and backgrounds and yet we're
somehow expected to be able to sit
around the table and and make incredible
things together with very few
misunderstandings and obviously that
doesn't happen and sort of you're
devoting your time to exactly this
question and so thank you very much for
being here thank you
great looking forward to this discussion
how did you get started with
thinking about this globalization world
in communication and training and
coaching oh well i've been dealing with
cross-cultural um
horticultural work for
quite a long time
uh i was born i can say that i'm kind of
a global nomad myself born in the u.s
having grown up in sweden and germany
back to the u.s and then immigrated to
israel
uh so i'm kind of an example of you know
what a global nomad is am israeli am i
american and my finnish and that's kind
of what the world is today you know
we're so
globally oriented and we relocate and we
live in different countries and work in
different countries and so we can't
really stereotype and say oh i'm just
american or i'm just israeli which makes
really understanding cultures uh very
different
but um
i worked for 20 years at the us embassy
in tel aviv where i was director of a
department that did a lot of
international education collaboration
and that's where i actually spearheaded
my first crest cultural uh training
model
and i left the embassy uh after 20 years
and started my own company together with
my partner and that's what we do we work
with organizations uh globally in even
out of israel
to what we call bridge the business
cultural differences so people can work
seamlessly together and minimize like
you said minimize those
misunderstandings that can be really a
deal breaker uh in many instances
so um that's what we do how big of a
problem is it you know how you know
you're taught you know deal breaker it's
a strong word and just to paint a
picture
how challenging is this what what we're
dealing with here i'll give you an
example we work with uh organizations
you know abraham accords right that was
a really big deal and israelis want to
work with uh uad organizations and vice
versa now we're we're all in the middle
east right so you would think that we
share a similar culture
uh and to an extent we don't but we do
but in business
the uae culture or their cultural values
are so different from those of israel
give you an example we as israelis are
um
we're very fast moving we're very direct
right straight to the point uh we build
relationships uh according to the
business interaction that we're involved
with
and then
we want to do business with uh somebody
or an organization in the uae right and
what really is one of their core values
is that trust is built through building
relationships now that doesn't happen in
a three-day business trip you know an
israeli applying to the u.a thinking
he'll come back with you know the
initial understanding of the business
transaction it's not going to happen you
need to build that relationship you need
to cultivate that relationship you need
to build trust and only after you build
trust and that can take even up to six
months it can even take a year i've
heard of organizations that it's taking
them two years to build that trust
and so that's very different to us that
if we take a u.s organization american
values are we bill americans build trust
through competency to achievement
through uh people who've achieved stuff
people who can make decisions you know
america's a very individualistic
oriented culture
and uh
going into other cultures like uae or
even asian cultures
uh which are exactly the opposite
they're not individualistic they're
collectivists so again that relationship
building takes time that trust building
takes time and if you don't understand
that then you kind of push
too much your that relationship isn't
that big that relationship will never
transition into a successful business
relationship
so those are one of the things that
people need to understand
uh communication you know we all speak
english right but
the way we speak english the way we
communicate is very different we are
again in israel we're very direct we've
been being called aggressive
communicators you know we very straight
on and when we work with people from the
cultures we kind of need to
you know be much softer and uh and our
integration should be different and
there's a lot of differences that you
know it's it's all a matter of
perception the way
each one of us sees themselves is very
different from how other people see
ourselves and that's what we need to be
aware of so what we do is we actually
build that perception in making people
are aware first of all that you know
the way you see yourself is not the way
another culture might perceive you
and so um
and there's many more examples if you
take um
leadership okay leadership in india uh
is very different than leadership in usa
uh india is very hierarchical uh top
down kind of a culture uh employees
expect their leaders their managers to
tell them to give them instructions very
straight on detailed instructions you
know they don't
look too much out of the box and let's
say an indian leader like that is
managing uh people in a u.s company
and he will be very you know
micromanaging that won't go well so
there's a lot of aspects into culture
that needs to be understood to be able
to work together seamlessly
and so i'm hearing a few things first
i'm hearing that it you know when it
comes to
to the business relationships it's about
trust and then you're you're pointing
out that different
groups have different ways of developing
trust some groups trust is more of a of
an issue of relationship based that i
trust this person because i know this
person on a personal level and some of
them it's more i don't need to know them
on a personal level but i need to know
that they're competent right enough that
i can trust them right and but then
you're also saying that that you know we
have the the the communication itself
and though and besides just the business
relationship and we also have management
barriers or can and communication
barriers that that that span beyond the
complexity of the english language and
the english grammar that we might learn
and so
you know
you know i'm convinced it's a it sounds
it sounds like it's it's a it's an
interesting topic that that probably not
enough people are talking about
is that does it really
impact you know businesses today does it
really impact leaders around the world
that is it really making them
fail in some levels or not reach their
their full potentials well um
it is because uh i mean i i
i think that is the core of the issue
otherwise we wouldn't have any work
right but
uh yes it does i mean um
uh i work with a lot of uh high-tech
organizations that have that are you
know r d is in israel and uh then
entities are built in the us and so you
have americans and israelis working
together now
we all have this uh illusion that you
know we're very similar okay we dress
the same we like mcdonald's you know we
also like sushi we don't we hear the
same music there we're kind of in a
comfort zone you know israel is going
into america we kind of feel that we
have americans but when the two sides
work together
uh there's a lot of cultural
misunderstandings uh
coming from
communication coming from how project
management is viewed how is it
implemented uh us is a very process
oriented okay a very uh organized kind
of a culture and it's really is much
more spontaneous you know risk taking
you know let's launch this we're at 70
percent you know it's okay you know fix
the bugs as we go along
and
when you work with the u.s culture you
work with the german culture and you try
to you know launch something that hasn't
been tested fully or isn't 100 full
proof
uh you're going to have a lot of
cultural clashes and those clashes are
going to impact whether we want to work
together whether we can work together
whether there's some synergy in the way
we work our work styles our process our
implementation of different projects and
that can definitely cause that can be as
i said it can really be a game changer
in whether
organizations can work together if you
take mergers for example if you take um
organizations that uh buy out a merge
with uh other organizations that aren't
from different cultures if you don't
align those two cultures into one
cultural build the new what we call one
team culture
is it ain't gonna work right there's
gonna be different management styles
different leadership styles different
work styles all of that impacts the
success of the organization and
eventually productivity and revenue
interesting
what what can be done so i know that
you're working with with leaders and
organizations but if you know maybe by
you by understanding what your work
better we can understand what what is
sort of a
scalable solution to this but but what
ways are there to mitigate these
differences that you've been observing
so what we do is uh through you know
workshops and different processes we
teach uh skill sets methodology
methodology methodology
in how
how to um learn how to how to understand
the different cultural signals so that
effectiveness is not compromised we're
working with people from other cultures
who may have different working styles so
the key point here is that effectiveness
is not compromised the goals will have
the same goals but the approach to those
different goals is what differs and so
we we teach them all we we go through a
very cultural dimensions you know
communication risk taking time concept
you know time is not just a clock on the
wall sure it's a cultural value how
people view time how people view
project management and that will vary
from culture to culture so we what we
teach is we teach awareness first of all
let's be aware of the fact that we're
not all the same okay even though our
goals are the same and um and we also
teach um
uh what we call cultural agility
being agile enough once you have the
skill sets to recognize we're all going
to make mistakes you know even i make
you know mistakes we're all going to
make mistakes
key is how do we jump back from those
mistakes how if we make a mistake at
least we're aware that okay something
didn't work here maybe it's culturally
oriented and how could i fix that
because when you're not aware you'll
keep making the same mistakes over and
over again and not understanding why it
doesn't work so how do we identify when
we're making a mistake because i can
imagine a situation in which i go along
and i have a an hour-long meeting and
i'm not even i'm not even aware that
i've i've done something
that would constitute a mistake or that
would lead to a breach of trust or or a
setback how do we even know
well if that uh business relationship
doesn't uh transition into a sustainable
you know business transaction or even
any kind of business transaction
and it's not about the product you're
trying to sell then i assume it's
because you haven't really built the
right dynamics but it's also a matter of
knowledge knowing which cultures are
more
uh relationship oriented which cultures
are more task oriented for example if we
go take the germans or the american
cultures they're very task for it we
don't really need to like i said before
we don't really need to build a
relationship on the other hand you know
going into asia cultures or south
american cultures we need to build that
relationship because otherwise we won't
be able to move forward to our business
transactions interesting
so how does how is your work with
with these
with these leaders how does i mean what
do you actually do with them in the
day-to-day or with the organizations
okay what we usually do is um depends on
the organization of course but what we
usually do is uh
we do a full day of a workshop right
where we do what we call
um
covering all the different uh cultural
uh aspects of their work whatever that
happens to be but but we identify what
cultures what is the market that they
want to enter what are the where the
people they want to work with and
we give them a whole skill set of
knowledge
of what that culture is about and we
compare it to their own culture we say
here we're very similar but here we're
very different
and that's what we're going to work on
so that when they leave that workshop
they have skill sets of how to identify
those differences and there's always
those aha moments oh now i understand
what i didn't know before and then we do
like a coaching process uh once a month
once every two months because you know
every new behavior needs to be um
needs to be assimilated it's going to
take time because you know i can teach
them all about indian culture but the
next time their indian colleague on the
phone
uh will not deliver something as
promised on monday morning right away
we'll go back to our own behavior and
you know whatever that behavior is so it
takes time to understand how to
communicate what we want in a culturally
mindful way so that the other person
understands and so and also for us to
understand when an indian person says
sure no problem i'll have it to you by
monday morning doesn't really mean he'll
have it to us playing monday morning so
we need to also it's a two-way street
it's not enough that one side learns
about the other side's culture and the
other side needs to also learn so that
they can bridge those two and also we do
after we've done bridging both sides we
do kind of round the table
uh discussion or workshop where we say
okay now that everybody understands each
other's culture
let's put those issues you had before
the table and let's see now how they can
be solved
you know having
the cultural knowledge interesting and
so
how do we scale this how do we how do we
now bring this to more of a global
scale of understanding
is this something that that people need
to learn when you know when they're in a
position of leadership is this something
that perhaps needs to be ingrained in us
earlier on
in our lives how relevant is this for
people who are not necessarily in
leadership positions
well it doesn't really depend you know
culture is not just between countries
you know each country has its own
subcultures too you know in america you
have new york uh mexican-americans your
iranian-americans
uh
indian-americans there's a lot of
subcultures in what we call you know
america every one of those have also
their own
culture that they bring to the table so
it isn't just crossing countries it's
really crescent cultures and if we talk
talking on urbanism on an organizational
level
uh
one of the big um
visions
that are already implemented is
diversity and inclusion right in global
organizations so in order to implement
diversity and inclusion then you really
need to be a global leader and what you
need to have as a global leader you need
to have that understanding of how do you
manage people or in your team come from
different backgrounds who come from
diverse backgrounds who have different
uh work habits different forms
communication different ways for you to
motivate them or to give them feedback
so it isn't just class in countries it's
also
in you know increasing grain
in every corporate culture to be part of
the organizational culture in a
corporation
interesting
so
taking this you know one step further if
you know anybody who's listening here
you know where we're all working with
different people around the world that's
you know part of the assumption of this
global ecosystem we're in what is
something that i should leave this
conversation with
that i can then implement either in my
own understanding or in my own behavior
as i am approaching my next my next
meeting with anybody around the world
what is sort of some some lesson that i
can take with me or something that i can
practice
that will make me a better global
collaborator
um there's one mantra that we always try
to inspire instill in our clients don't
assume that you know
because you might not know your
assumptions are based on your own
cultural values
and they might not be the same for
another person so you know apply
curiosity apply and they apply asking
questions in order to understand
um
uh
there's a very famous quote by peter
drucker you know he's one of the
worldwide management consultants and he
says what managers or leaders should do
is the same across the globe
but how
depends on the culture
like how it depends on the culture i
think that's the
that that's at the end of the holy grail
here right i mean we're talking about
both i'm hearing that we have this
dissonance between both this this more
generalistic understanding
of of trust building and relationship
building and the other hand we have this
localization factor which says well this
but you have to really understand it for
each situation separately and you have
to adapt
given every every situation so it's not
enough to just be cognizant of it you
have to actually practice and understand
who this other person is in front of you
and and even if you're talking to a
person from a specific region even then
you have micro cultures within that and
so
uh it sounds like it's a it's it's quite
a quite an interesting challenge and and
it sounds like you're you're having fun
tackling it which which is really
exciting to hear
and let's add to the co uh to to that
another layer we at the end of the day
we're all individuals right right we all
carry a certain dna culture that is
based on our background our uh our
upbringing our schooling where we lived
what sandwiches we were born into all of
that is that individual so you add that
as a layer on top of you know
national cultural differences and life
is fun
i love it i wanna but i love we love our
work we really do it's uh very inspiring
and we truly truly believe in this
division also
uh cultural agility here we're
and we're not the only ones i mean
organizations across the globe really
understand the importance of building
cultural agility in their leaders and
then for their leaders you know to take
that
uh down to their teams and so forth and
so on to create what we called
um
a culturally competent organization and
operate from a multicultural perspective
that's not a given that's something that
needs to be learned
it's incredible i wanna thank you very
very much this was wonderful and
insightful um continue making a positive
impact on leaders and and globalization
around the world and thank you very much
for being here thank you for having me
then a pleasure